before we get started members can I
check that you've got the addendum that
you've seen it ready
[Music]
very good evening everybody
our physicists right Development
Committee 13th of February 2020 our
usual emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
to the chamber our assembly point will
be at the public car park at the side of
the Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please don't return to the building
unless the permission has been given to
do so by council staff please note the
meeting will be audio recorded and if
you've got your mobile with you please
turn it silent or off thank you item 1
apologies for absence have been received
from councillor Wharton and that takes
us on to item to substitute members
councillor gooding on non members
attending accounts the sparing
councillor row counts to step toe counts
the Wilkinson counselor mr. hoi counts
the mrs. hoi
item four minutes of the meeting held on
23rd of January 2020 if you're happy for
me to sign those as a correct and
accurate record of that meeting thank
you
declarations of interest sort the top
first chairman item six non-procurement
rest we've got to being the county
councillor for the road southward which
that item using and item item ten as
chairman of the investment board other
Community Interest nine sorry Thank You
chairman other pecuniary interest plays
on item nine and non-pecuniary interest
as the Riley Town Council though I
didn't
the mates in a private town council
exactly the same as counselor row
chairman that's a Wilson you had your
hand up non-punitive interest in item
nine member of Oxford District Council
and also on the Investment Board okay
guys Stanley item knowing but not on the
interest in America
thank you that's a Western a
non-pecuniary I believe I the county
councillor for the copy warden also my
daughter lived at the back of the unit
has been developed raves non-pecuniary I
believe I've had a number of
communications with officers regarding
item 9 and as a result of that I've been
advised that I could be accused of
predetermination therefore I will have
to exclude myself from the vote on that
one
so the interest is
item 6 Bingham M Ward member for the
area and item 9 non-pecuniary being a
member of the investment board so
everyone right thank you
item 6 this is one that was deferred
from last time just a reminder there is
information on the addendum which you've
all told me you've seen got a copy off
and and read okay thank you
Thank You chairman this application
relates to the wider Business Park site
that's off Cherry Orchard Way and it
relates to part of this site to the
southeast corner the application is for
reserved matters relating to landscaping
only following outline planning
permission having been granted for the
whole site relating to a 2015 consent
reserved matters have already been
approved in relation to this parcel of
the site under a 2018 consent and that
related to layout of the site including
if we can take you to the layout plan in
to zoom out of that plan please
all the way out yes thank you
so including our single large building
to the central portion of the site
adjacent to the spy mode car parking
area to the north of that in a service
yard to the south so this application
relates to landscaping details including
new boundary treatment to the site a
boundary wall to the to a part of the
southern boundary which runs along the
red line and enclosing fence would also
feature a top of this boundary wall the
proposal also seeks changes to ground
levels across the site so the scale of
the building doesn't increase from that
already approved at the previous
reserved matters stage what the site did
to originally were sloped gently
downwards from west to east and what
they sought to do across the site is
provide level ground so this part of the
building is no higher than was
originally approved and they sought to
level the site in relation to the spine
road to the west the site also had some
changes in relation to ground levels to
the east and portion and these are best
shown on the section plans if we could
take you to those
so this is the same site you can see and
if you're looking at a b and c through
sections across the site i'm going from
south to north but I just take B as an
example this shows where my the pointer
is the adjacent commercial property to
the south and the land level there and
then it shows the direction northwards
going across the service yard here so
the building is just off that plan so
the Green Line shows the original site
level which had an earth bond and what's
proposed is to very slightly raise the
land level but only very slightly and
put a retaining wall in and then you can
see that the land here is raised
slightly the land level rises very
gently up to a point four meters into
the site and this area would be
landscaped so there's this landscaped
buffer along here which include tree
planting that would provide a screen in
time and then the site level then falls
very gently across the service yard
towards the building to the north the
key consideration in this determination
is really the effect on the amenity of
the adjoining commercial premises to the
south in relation to the land levels
that have happened there members had the
opportunity to visit the site and
observe the ground level changes that
have happened relative to this
neighboring unit the proposed changes to
the land levels are considered
acceptable as set out in the officer
report and the recommendations airman is
therefore one of approval subject to the
recommended conditions
just turn the microphone on máxima five
minutes I'll let you know any of a
minute to go okay yeah good evening to
you all first of all thank you very much
to give me the opportunity to speak in
favor of the application tonight and and
thank you for the case offices
recommendation for approval and members
of the planning committee have since the
January planning committee where the
decision was deferred due to the need
for clarification on a number of issues
they now have had the opportunity to
visit the site to assess for themselves
the impact of the proposed level changes
to the service yard and they proposed
boundary treatments on the adjoining
land at that meeting
the council's officer obviously talked
us around the site and mentoring in
considerable detail in terms of the
issues that were raised by the
application and and took lots of
questions from the planning committee
members and I certainly went away from
that meeting feeling that everyone
understood the application that was
before them and I've now got a little
list of issues that I just really wanted
we're really really just issues of
clarification really arising out of some
of the sort of confusion at the last at
last month's Planning Committee firstly
there was a strip of land between the
boundary of the IP code development and
the land in mr. rands ownership it is an
average two meters in width and is in
the ownership of Southwark Borough
Council
it is not fenced so you can't actually
see that when you go to site the current
design of the boundary treatment we are
discussing tonight was discussed and
agreed with the adjoining owner mr. on
we did actually look at a number of
different options for the boundary
treatment but after an approach from mr.
on we actually adopted his proposed
design so therefore I'm clear that the
submitted proposed bounded treatment was
specifically requested by mr. Rahn and
agreed with him and reflects his wishes
at the time of the submission of the
planning application
the proposed finishing levels of the
service yard adjacent to the boundary
were agreed by mr. Ryan's technical
representative there was a joint
inspection of the site on the 2nd of
October and the levels were agreed the
proposed service job design reduces the
potential impact of surface water
drainage onto the adjoining land to zero
the proposed regraded service yard now
slopes away from the boundary to drain
in the middle of the service yard which
then drains into the nearby balancing
pond and then onwards away from the plot
any drainage from the proposed landscape
strip is via a french drain which will
be constructed on the base of the
retained wall within the application
boundary the proposed boundary treatment
including the landscape trip retaining
wall are all within the application
boundary the retaining wall can be
constructed without the need to access
or use any other land in the ownership
of mr. Ahn and this has been confirmed
by our contractors really construction
the two point four meter paladin fence
which will be constructed on the
boundary is not opaque it is wire mesh
in style and will not any way impact on
light levels or amenity on the building
on mr. Ryan's land the type of fence
that will be used on this southern
boundary will be exactly the same as was
inspected on site by the Planning
Committee members during their visit on
Saturday similarly the proposed
landscapes strip the revised service
yard levels have no impact whatsoever on
the immunity or the light levels in the
adjoining buildings in summary HPD are
strongly of the opinion that the
proposed service yard levels and
boundary treatment would not have any
detrimental impact on their joining land
and buildings and planning applications
should be approved without further delay
and of our non-members wish to make any
comment on this one obviously we've had
the benefit of making making this our
second second time so councillor Yves
just before you start so I'm sorry but
there's no public interaction in this
meeting it is just for members sorry
Kathy leaves thank you
the visit was asked after there was a
good deal of confusion at the last
meeting where this came up over the
actual levels when we went over there I
took a laser level over there and the
levels do appear to be as has been
presented to us one thing that does come
to mind one thing that was said to us
when we were over there the fencing that
is proposed to be put round it was
suggested that there be planting that'll
be allowed to grow up it now if that's
the case then that could be a case that
that might impede on the light next door
I wonder if we could impose a condition
just to suggest that the IP IP Co or
whoever actually owns the site there
take responsibility for keeping the
growth off of that why offence Thank You
Stanley
Thank You chairman I did appreciate the
visit I thought that gave a great deal
of insight as to what was happening and
how it would look at that there was a
little thing that perhaps you it's not
so important but the drainage was given
that the drainage would be going out to
the crouch I think it's I was told on
site but I do think it's going out to
the river leading onto the crouch but
nevertheless that's that suits suits my
thanks of that information so where it's
going and it shouldn't have any impact
on on the downstream from there thank
you did you start to pass comment on
what the landscaping schema is described
as at this moment let's go back to the
yeah if you can zoom in maybe to the
southern boundary so along this southern
boundary there are a number of different
species of plant proposed it's a
landscaped buffer so it's supposed to
have some sort of visual amenity value
and there are a number of trees as well
but they're sporadically planted there's
no specific proposal for any vegetation
to grow specifically up the the palisade
fence so I don't see any specific
objection to putting the recommended
condition on if it's a concern actually
a you know sort of more opaque you know
boundary to the heights might be a
problem but there would be potential for
the vegetation to grow up and around the
shrubs and the like behind but it will
be managed and maintained by the company
looking after the whole site
recommendation printed on six point one
going over to six point two and asked
for those members in favor of the
approval to indicate thank you an item
is approved item seven site of twenty
two main road Hockley again there is
information on the addendum relating to
this one Thank You chairman so this
application relates to this site here in
hockey town center but adjoining the
residential area
they've got residential properties to
the west the north and the east the
application is to convert the existing
building to the front of the site to
form ten to bed flats plus one
commercial unit I can take you to the
leg
just raise it up
this application is a resubmission
following refused of a very similar
scheme in December last year this
earlier application was refused because
the scheme omitted any any commercial
use within the units so it's wholly
residential the previous scheme
there was concern relating to the fact
that the hockey area action plan seeks
to retain the vitality and viability of
the town center and that this site
having previously been in a commercial
you should retain some of that element
the revised proposal has sought to
address this reason for refusal by
including one commercial unit proposed
for retail use and that will be in this
part of the building here this would
occupy one of the flats previously
proposed so one additional commercial
unit one less residential flat the
proposal essentially only changes in
relation to this part of the site the
remainder is exactly the same as the
scheme you had before you in in December
obviously changing this to a retail unit
has required some fenestration changes
to the front so this would now be a
glazed shop front whereas there was some
windows through a residential property
previously proposed in addition one of
the pockets said there the same amount
of parking and the same layout of
parking as previously proposed but one
of the spaces is now a visitor space or
could be utilized for the retail units
but each of the flats has the same
amount of parking as was previously
considered in December the only other
change resulting from the inclusion of
the retail unit effects viability of the
site in relation to affordable housing
so what we've done is we've had the
viability assessment retested and that
has come out as expected that the scheme
now cannot viably provide any
contribution to affordable housing the
application chairman is one of Approval
subject to the recommended conditions
thank you have a speaker on this one
browning you know when you've had four
hi good evening my name is Jonathan
browning and I owner and developer of 22
Maynard Hockley in our last meet in
November I sought to turn the retail
unit into the residential to keep the
whole building as a residential and not
to mix use development as per the
existing approved scheme the decision
was made that the retail unit would have
to remain as per the approved scheme as
members would say this as to greater
loss to the high street same reflecting
on the points raised that evening I've
submitted the scheme that reverts back
to that of the original approved with
the retail unit to remain at the front
of the building as shown having started
this application back in May to 18 I am
keen to get a resolution and decision on
it this evening if possible I won't go
over all ground on where it kind of left
me and my father's business financially
I hope that you find the plans put
forward to still be sympathetic to the
overall design and hope I've managed to
meet your requirements with a retail
unit that you raised last time and I say
that just short and sweet thank you for
your time members wish to speak on this
one counts Reeves
thank you Jeff I'm glad to see the
retail unit retained and thank you for
that just one small thing that has
actually been mentioned by residents
there is the balconies that are in
particular around the back do overlook
Gardens that are at the back there I
went there this afternoon to go and see
and I do appreciate that that is the
case now I'm not looking to change
things but I wonder if we could ask the
developer to instead of putting clear
glass in those balconies to put obscure
glass in there the reasoning being that
when people are sitting down inside the
flats they look straight out into the
garden now I know that when they go on
to the balcony they will still be
looking over the gardens but what it
does mean is that there is a degree of
privacy that is then afforded to the
people with the gardens who are
overlooked by the balcony if that
condition could be agreed I think that
that would be advantageous to the
residents who are adjacent
I think text technique technically we
need to make sure we're not raising new
issues because we're very clearly the
top paragraph and 7.4 said what are
reasons for refusal were however if we
just take a little bit of advice here I
think we could look to deal with that
under the condition 3 which looks which
in States or details of all external
facing and roofing materials including
but not limited to although those know
what was on in there but that's what the
gist of that is including windows and
doors for use in construction and shall
be approved prior to their use on the
site so we can have that conversation
bearing in mind that so I think that
would effectively cover that
other members indicated we have a
recommend date
oh sorry counselor Weston yes just a
quick question it's or the unit itself
is that the whole length of the the
building as as was the unit Oh is there
a flat include you in the beginning of
that with that unit sorry
so if briefly I have got the elevation
plan as well that might be clearer you
take you to the elevation plan so this
is the front elevation so as you as you
look at that and from the street this is
the proposed retail unit with that
glazed sorta frontage and then there are
these windows and doors serve the two
residential flats at ground-floor
cummock there's two ground-floor flats
one commercial retail unit adjacent to
them remembers recommendation printed on
seven-point-one going through 16 points
through 27.3 remembers happy those
members in favor please indicate thank
you that's item is carried
item 8 particularly notes again
information on the addendum regarding
this one land to the loss of London Road
Raley I think just remembers we've we've
got a clear office a recommendation for
deferment so I think we probably won't
have discussion about this one unless
someone's got a particular issue but we
do need to hear the officers
presentation first Thank You chairman so
this application relates the strategic
site between North Lane to the north and
London Road to the south to the west of
Raley the site overall benefits from
outline planning permission granted
under a 2015 consent if I can take you
to the next plan and zoom out of that
plan a little please so this plan is now
orientated can you zoom out just
slightly I don't if it doesn't seem out
anymore if it doesn't it's not a problem
so this plan is orientated the other way
from the location plan you've just seen
so you've got raw Earth Lane here to
this side and you've got London Road to
this side and the application relay it's
an application for reserved matters for
part of the spine Road in the central
portion of the site so the spy mode
already has reserved matters approval
and to the northern section in the south
and this application relates to two
sections one just south of the the brook
that bisects the site and one smaller
section just to the north of that
reserved matters the application relates
to landscaping appearance layout scale
and access so all those reserved matters
are for consideration a bridge across
the site would it will be proposed at
some stage but that's not part of the
current proposal a swale is proposed to
the north and part of the carriageway in
both sections and there's footways and
cycleways are included and to both foot
ways to both sides and a cycleways
included on one side some changes in the
land levels are proposed
they vary between 20 centimeters and 2.5
meters getting closer to the bridge
because the land is going to have to
rise up at some point there are also
lowerings of the land levels but just to
a small degree members will note on the
addendum that a consultation response
has now been received from Essex County
Council highways which does not
recommend the application favorably
there's some technical issues with the
the kind of Road layout this road would
be expected to be adopted by as its
County Council and given that to the
recommendation from offices is therefore
one of deferral so this items going to
come back to us again when the technical
detail is sorted so to save wasting your
time members if you're in favor of the
defer run please indicate all right
thank you that's a Miss deferred for now
item nine land adjacent 14 cambro close
again information on the addendum are
you ready
Thank You chairman and she noticed
application relates to land adjacent
Fulton home row close and the photo
before you shows the application sigh
and shows that he's a vacant open plot
of land located on the northern side of
Hamburg close in a prominent position at
the end of a Vista when entering her
burrow close the site is opening nature
and comprises sycamore tree this tree is
not covered by a tree preservation order
okay Planning Commission has been sought
to erect a two-story building comprising
two two-bedroom flats and layout five
car parking spaces so yeah layout of
five car parking spaces including one
visitor space and private amenity space
the humanity space proposed for the
ground floor flat would be provided
through the provision of a rear garden
together a terrorists area to the front
measuring a total of approximately 54
square meters the proposed first will
flat would have amenity space in the
form of a balcony this this is to be
provides a fun overlooking the green
area to northern into the site which are
open green fields and would measure a
property nine square meters the private
means his basic implies the council's
SPD to housing design a secured cycle
store is being proposed in this corner
of the site and which would front on to
Hamburg closer and would comprise space
for two bicycles and a bin store would
also be incorporated into a recessed
area set with inside elevation the
building I'd like to refresh you on the
the previous site plan that was
submitted which is for the applications
refused previously back in August and
last ate his book beautiful members of
the planning committee in August 2000 19
M and was refusing the base that the
proposed development lacked a visitor
car parking space this application has
been submitted in order to overcome the
previous reasons for refusal which
relate to lack of a Vista car parking
space and as you can see with the layout
this is front in Hamburg close and there
is for car parking space laid out there
was 2 per flats this was the application
that's previously refused this was the
cycle space that was previously proposed
and if I take you on to back to the
block plan
and as you can see the car parking laid
out to the front
oh really building but fronting on to
I'm very close not that dissimilar from
current layout of these two round street
scene access is gained off Hamburg
closed whereby there would be an area
hard stand laid out to accommodate five
car parking spaces the car parking
includes one visitor bay the car park is
later in tandem arrangement all car
parking spaces measured to the preferred
base and standards which is 5.5 by 2.9
meters the sizing proposal is adequate
for tandem parking the axis is
considered acceptable would not have an
impact upon a highway safety the car
parking part proposed comply fully with
the parking standards and the cycle
store which has been incorporating
theory regarding that could accommodate
two cycle spaces like I said before this
is in a different location to what was
previously proposed but is adequate for
the scale of development as it comes
lies with the car parking standards
which require one cycle cycle space for
dwelling taking you on to the elevations
as you can see the only of proposed
changes is for the provision of a
terraced area at the ground floor and a
falcon at first floor which both front
off onto the open green fields to the
north there is a cantilever projection
introduced in the elevation that fronts
on to have very close these changes
would not result in any additional
detrimental impact upon the occupiers
neighbours properties by way of causing
excessive overshadowing as a result of
being overbearing or cruising
overlooking and lots of privacy the
proposed development 1 for approval
subject to the recommended conditions
thank you thank you have two speakers on
this
I actually director of front
architecture with the agents for the
application and speaks down behalf for
to counsel you beware as the case
officer has mentioned this application
was before you last year and was refused
for one point only that reason for
refusal was for the lack of visitor
parking as confirmed by the officer we
now have a visitor space all parking
spaces are 5.5 42.9 fully meet policy
and all fully compliant there's been a
number of objections on this application
raised by local residents I'll go
through some of those there's been
mentioned or covenant on the land that's
not a planning consideration and
shouldn't be apologies yeah there's been
a number of objections on the
application firstly there's there was
comment on a covenant on the land it's
non material planning matter and
shouldn't be something that should raise
reason for refusal I don't know we heard
of what I mentioned before but I was
just saying that the application has
come forward today in a very similar
form as the previous application but
overcoming the only one reason for a
refusal that one reason for a fuse will
being the lack of visitor parking which
we now achieve in a fully compliant in
that so I'm very principally all the
other elements of the application stay
as they were which there was no refusal
raised on that basis so our approach
that was to that the the current parking
layout to show what we have now where we
have five parking spaces two spaces per
unit plus a visitor parking space all
5.5 but
two point nine and a fully policy
compliant other objections that are
raised are in reference to the drainage
of the site the applicant welcomes
condition for the drainage which is
commonly found on any application the
suitable drainage strategy will be
submitted as a condition prior to
commencement of the application now that
drainage strategy may well include
something such as a attenuation tank
which will take in the the surface
runoff and distribute that a slower rate
and in theory may actually help the
residents if they feel they've got a
problem with the surface drainage so it
will be designed by a suitable civil
engineer and submitted a pre
commencement condition so that's agreed
in writing prior to any work being
carried out there was other objections
raised to the relocation of the lamppost
the lamppost is proposed to be relocated
we're aware that there's residents of
race concern about lighting to the
footpaths either side on applications
we've had in the past we have had
lighting schemes conditioned so we could
provide low-level bollard lighting along
there again that would like the footpath
adjacent site and actually again
improved the situation for the reasons
there the bollard line would be
low-level enough that the spread of
light would be a positive contribution
to the footpath but wouldn't have a
negative effect on the amenities of the
adjacent properties yeah I think another
objection was the loss of the sycamore
tree which the case officer is mentioned
it's not TP out it's not been raised as
an objection by any statutory authority
and a suitable replacement tree has been
from has been suggested which again the
the applicant welcomes as a as a
condition to the applicator as a
condition to any approval in terms of
what
see we are compliant in parking we are
fully compliant we are compliant we've
got your amenity space national minimum
standard storage areas all of those
things have not changed since the
previous application which he didn't
raise a reason for refusal on and the
one point that you did raise refusal on
has been addressed and he's now fully
policy compliant thank you
not wasting time talking about that five
minutes and thank you know when you've
had four you put my picture up please
I want the one with the the drawing
please P for the other one next one down
thank you everyone see that right
thank you right I'm back here again I'm
to talk on behalf of the community this
is a community play area that you're
thinking of getting rid of again there's
got copier on but no material
consideration but it is a place for my
children of special needs they play
there all the time you can see this
there's no ball games on it another
picture will come up and show you design
is shoddy it's a complete redesign of
this whole thing nothing to do with just
one parking space number fourteen faces
the side of it it's not facing the field
so number fourteen it always gonna be
facing someone else's front door or the
side of a building it's not acceptable
to put that there
so that's wrong already the cantilever
in the balcony would have adverse
effects on them and causing overlooking
and loss of privacy plus the noise level
would increase there of daily increased
noise stress light pollution and
overshadowing of their home the relevant
planning history before in 2004 did say
that it was a loss of informal space
harmful and insufficient provision for
immunity spaces just because the new
people get it nothing's changed just cuz
it wasn't mentioned in 2019 doesn't mean
it's gone away you're taking our space
this is an infill which elected
councillors here last time and said they
would refuse it if it was a private
application rather than councils own
application itself the council should
act beyond reproach and not expect
preferential treatment to that of its
residents you chuck it check it out
check it out whatever Amin T space
you've now changed the immunity space
you've now got a spoken-- e by the way
that balcony is gonna face a street lamp
ground floor may have changed the design
has changed as well bin storage you're
not going to use norton airy bins you
didn't mention it you've got bulk bins
great big fault bins
where are they going to go because
they're not going in the cycle shed you
got it I'm gonna put bulk bins somewhere
on there that's gonna be a health hazard
you're destroying my tree I asked to get
a teepee on it was refused I asked three
times to put a teepee on it since August
he refused it saying it doesn't really
matter because even if there was one on
it planning policy overruled to tpo so
what's the point it wouldn't have
mattered anyway it doesn't comply
parking and highway safety this is on a
junction if you could show the picture
please of the actual junction itself
tandem parking is Lund like to be you
ties in its potential especially if both
cars are in regular use acceptance by
this by the council means they require
additional provision of unallocated
parking spaces ie they're not going to
park in their parking spaces you know
that it's the last resort on your
standards so you know full well people
will not park there it says it itself in
your policy you're not adhering to it
they never part properly probably use it
for something else
probably the bins this was the whole
reason it was refused last time and the
bays it says very clearly this design is
inclusive
it could be adapt to the ground floor
well guess what if it's gonna be
adaptive where's my disabled bait where
is it it's not big enough for a disabled
Bay you've not done that in your parking
so it's exclusive and it's
discrimination developed must be refused
for that they're lighting yeah bollards
great will knocking to them at night
it's the most important light of the
t-junction and we won't be able to see
the other one on the other side I've
written to you all you all know this the
one on the other side will not be moved
they'll be facing a balcony I'm sure
they're asked to get that moved to
flooding and surface water great ideas
but frankly is destroying a tree and
natural soakaway there will be flooding
I read it and it says possible so Kuwait
possibly this possibly that you could
agree to it but the point being their
suggestions you're letting the develop
it aside after you've got the approval
not good enough
Natural England habitat report says
significant impact on the zone of
influence I guess what let's just give
you a hundred and twenty quick that'll
do you're already gonna pay it to
yourselves that is pathetic this is
climate change it's a play area it's a
green space you're ruining the carbon
footprint of a place you wanted to do
better for undiscussed 'add that you're
doing this or even considering it I get
the point
social housing I get the point but this
has got Covenant on it this is a green
space it was left empty for a reason
you're trying to do worse the detriment
of the character the appearance a
locality it's unsafe and it impacts
health and well-being it creates a crime
and disorder and the fear of crime dark
lighting pitch dark I hope you watch my
video pitch dark out there
we need those lights moving them is
going to cause one or the other alleyway
and where it's done suit they're moving
the alleyway on the other side not near
your front doors so you will be pitched
not going to your front door every day
if they knew
bless us and bollards and waste so
Sabrina with your disability you can't
walk down there you'll knock over it are
you getting it this is the lowest level
of families here we are single mothers
we are social housing this is a social
housing estate it was originally built
as a social housing estate we have got
every diverse and disability mental
disability physical disability with how
many have we got at least two disabled
blue badges people and you're gonna do
all of this to us for a bit of land that
is poultry land grab
pure profit it is not in the local plan
but you're gonna do it anyway I say
shame and it's shoddy and I think if you
got any sense you'll refuse it thank you
very much
cancer Reeves with your interest you
wish to speak because I'll give you the
opportunity to speak and then you're
going to leave okay Rick thank you thank
you I have had numerous correspondence
with the managing director and legal aid
II I completely disagree with them but I
think in the interest of the threat
that's been made I would rather not
actually open myself to a possibility of
being reprimanded okay thank you
right to our visiting members counts the
road Thank You chairman well here we are
again I totally understand the amount of
work that's gone into this application
and I totally understand that there's
certain situations that cannot be held
or cannot be discussed as a refusal for
a planning application however all along
the way I've asked officers to make sure
that we are not leaving ourselves
hanging out to dry here I've asked that
all legal issues be addressed before
this comes to planning again and that
hasn't happened and I'm astounded
chairman quite frankly absolutely
astounded this is our application we we
could have withdrawn it I get the
application sounding in the planners
planners eyes but I'm sorry there's too
many issues outstanding legally for me
thank you yeah Thank You chairman Sharon
I have several concerns with this
application and I do appreciate the
opportunity given me to speak I would
like to put on record actually them that
we've sat in a number of times
complaining that the planners don't
understand parking policy of the gosset
side of the bays and that's been
rectified this evening so when thank you
very much I know we've had that we've
directed some criticism towards you as
obviously a work and the owner and
applicant for this developments is
watcher District Council this appears to
me personally to be a financially based
decision by some officers of the
council's sell off land with planning
permission to gain the financial reward
in doing so I spoke about this
application in August our August last
year and remain opposed to it for the
following reasons paragraph 127 of
section 12 of the National planning
policy framework requires planning
decisions to comply with certain
guidelines some of which are that must
function well and add to the overall
quality of the area must be sympathetic
to the local character and history it
must establish a strong sense of place
it must optimize
the potential of the site to sustain
appropriate amount of mix of development
including green and other public space
it must create spaces which are safe and
inclusive and promote health and
well-being with amenity for existing as
well as future users for existing as
well as future users this development
seeks to remove the only piece of
remaining open land for the existing
users so therefore it fails on that part
the National Policy planning policy
framework also advises the planet
decisions for development should ensure
that the developments do not undermine
the quality of life for residents and
moreover this is important bit it
requires not it advisors it requires the
permission should be refused for
developments of poor design and those
which fail to take opportunities
available to improve the character and
quality of the area and the way it
functions I would therefore chairman and
members ask yourselves the following
question does this development enhance
the quality of existing area or not if
the answer is no then the MPP F requires
you to refuse it policy H one of our own
core strategy requires that
intensification of smaller sites will be
resisted it does however allow some
infill developments and smaller sites
but only if it relates well to the
existing Street pattern density and
character chairman I'd like to draw you
and members attention to the committee
decision taken on the 6th of February
2004 for this application which was
refused on the basis that a build at
this location would be harmful to the
local area due to the loss of open space
for playing you will no doubt hear at
some point that the must only consider
in fact you've already heard that you
must only consider factors surrounding
the Vista parking as that was the reason
for refusal in August last year however
in doing so what you've been told about
us and that what they were leading to is
the potential for an appeal and the
financial implications to the council if
that appeal were upheld and costs were
awarded let's not forget here the
applicants us are we likely to appeal
against ourselves well obviously not
therefore that is not an issue in my
respectful submission I'd also urge
members to consider the motives behind
this application we are all elected
members of this council
we are sent here by the residents of our
respective wards they trust us to do the
right thing by them
if ruptured council wants to do the
right thing by the residents of hamburg
close then this application would have
been withdrawn and it will be withdrawn
now and leave the open space as it is it
is a place which enhances the area of
the close it enhances the life and the
well-being of the close and its
residents and yet the officers wish to
take that away from them this is not a
third pass developer approaching a
suppliant of planning permission to
build this is our own offices try to
sell the land with planning consent
thereby raising its market value to
generate funds that it appears to be
more important than the well-being than
the health of the residents of hamburg
close gemenon i am sympathetic to this
financial needs of this council and I
applaud the officers who are trying to
the best to make this budget work
however not or ever to the detriment of
the residents one final thing chairman I
would like to point out is I notice in
the opening today we have at least five
if not six members of the your
Development Committee who are also on
the investment board now I'll stand
corrected and maybe Chris could advise
me better on this but I would therefore
suggests that as I think it's investment
board that have decided to bring this
piece of land forward than they are
predetermined in this respect as they've
already made a decision to bring this
piece of land forward and therefore
cannot be capable of making an
uninformed and unpretty termined
decision this evening Chairman I
therefore urge you all to refuse this
application of the basis that it's
contrary to the policies I have stated
Thank You chairman Thank You councillor
mr. high Thank You chairman
I would like to start by saying that
this application is being put for by the
council I had when we as a council put
toward applications we should be
adhering to all of our policies and
making sure what we apply for is the
best of the best we we should be showing
an example to developers and I do not
feel that this application does that
moving on from there I have also asked
this council to withdraw the application
I did email a number of officers and
counselors who are involved in the
investment board including the managing
director I only had one counselor
respond thank you very much castle mrs.
rogue because she's the only one who
responded to me on that the others felt
to do so on a very important point of
withdrawing this and taking it back to
the investment board or now move on to
the actual application regardless of
what the officer said this is a new
application the building designer has
changed and the parking spaces have
design I've changed the amenity space
has changed so it's a new application it
the sizes have changed so this doesn't
prevent this committee from looking at
all of those and refusing on additional
grounds to the parking which is a which
was the original problem also this has
changed in other ways when this was
brought before the committee last time
there was the the council was certain
that they owned the land and had all
rights over the land that has changed
it's clearly shown on some residents
deeds that they have the right to use
that land and to walk over that land and
use it to seize will now that's not a
planning consideration we're told but
I'll come on to that now the policy dm3
of the local development framework
development management plan big title
item six avoiding the loss of important
open space which provides a community
benefit and/or visual focus in the
street scene this has already be stated
by the resident this is an important
play area used by residents this meets
Paula
seedy m36 sorry it's Roman numerals I'm
translating in my head and this and for
that they bust you you must have
considered carefully considered and
possible to positively address that
issue and that's these not done in this
report nor the previous report as it was
not to known at the time moving on and
this is the next one's quite important I
feel I'd I know the Chairman doesn't
learn the interaction with officers
while I'm doing my little visual speech
but if they would happen to have the
picture DM 3 or DM and the among version
4 or version 3 available 201 which shows
the parking space I would be grateful
because in the report it refers to this
is the one it refers to and I'll get
there in one moment because I make sure
I'll get this right
it refers to drawing number 200 revision
P 3 this is version 201 revision P 4 so
the report is written to a different
drawing I don't know where that drawing
is but that and if you look in paragraph
5 point 3 7 on page nine point nine you
will see actually this is where it says
the drawing number 200 revision P 3 we
have been shown drawing 201 or 203
vision v4 I have a copy it is there it's
the only one on the site there's not a P
3 on our website at all we only have P P
4 unless the the report states would
provide a garden area in excess of 50
meters for the ground floor flat so it's
cleared referring to a different plane
to the one shown and the one shown
tonight where the garden area is 45.7
square meters the garden area or
remediation space is brought up to the
54 meters by the addition at the top end
of the picture of a terrace area 9
meters squared
our emergency space policy says usable
remain 2d space I would suggest the 9
meter square immediacy space which is
basically just over a meter wide is more
of a pathway than a
usable amenity space so I believe we are
fading on a myth on grounds of amenity
space and I am unsure what the committee
would like want to do about the fact
they've been the report states one plane
and they're showing a different plane to
the one the report fir it refers to I
don't see how you could read a decision
on that basis the very least but
certainly it's open to refusal on that
basis
parking I do like parking and these
spaces appear to meet parking standards
however on the plans you've got to the
left you've got the immensity space and
the first Bay for flat one which is next
to the amenity space amenities space the
boundaries have yet to be decided
God suggests amenity space will have a
hard boundary then only Dovie will be a
fence or a wall body major defense when
a parking space is next to a fence it
requires a further meter of space on top
of the parking standards so the one
parking space there for fishes space
next to the amenity space fails our
parking stand because it requires a
further meter space that's clearly
stated in the Essex parking standards on
another point totally is one of not just
under-- that'd be embarrassing but I do
that one time we have
the the report on paragraph 3.3 mentions
that the fact that the layout of the
dwellings along this part of Henry are
closed front onto an open field they do
not the building to the right of this
development phases on to the development
not the open field this is why it's
going to lose light for the front door
that's why if the light disappears or
the front of the plot they will be in
darkness it is relevant
on that basis I'm now ready running out
of my voice I think which is seems to be
going but I would recommend oh no no
sorry there's one other point which was
in the conditions which is on page so
there's suggestive conditions on page
nine point three sort of three-quarters
way down after he says means of e
closure another boundary treatments
which would be the fencing we know that
you've got car parking layouts on
suggested if you do policy she really
should remove car parking layouts
because surely that's what this patty is
doing and that's what we're deciding I'd
be loath that the cows this council
might agree one or this committee agrees
one parking layoffs and it's then
changed at a later stage it looks like
he's just been cut and pasted to me
those that condition which shouldn't
really be there Massey chairman I think
the committee should reviews this
application the ground staff said or at
the very least defer defer it thank you
just for the sake of clarity item five
covered the declarations of interest all
members where appropriate to take an
advice and adhere and a reminder is for
members to determine their interest an
advice has been given and passed so I
don't believe we have any concerns on
that front members we've had a number of
people speak to us already on this item
please just remind you
that as members of the planning
committee we must determine on planning
issues and be focused on just what those
are and be mindful that on page nine
point five we have the reason for
refusal that was put for that not forth
that was that went through last time it
counts the Stanley you indicated please
Thank You chairman several things of
materialize since the last application
on the basis that the property is now a
completely different design to what was
brought up last time
could we put that picture back up with
doing can we keep the amenity space it
looks to me as though it's being
drastically uncut it's gone again
sorry chair we seem to have a bit of a
problem bringing the elevation drawings
back up again just bear with us
enjoy 201 turn Carol speak speaking we
don't work well or trample touched that
as I said the amenity space seems to
have drastically reduced plus the fact
that I don't think the amenity space of
this 9 meter square for the rear of the
property is sufficient for to
accommodate a play area for any children
that might be there might actually
occupy the the upper limit of which we
know that could possibly happen and I
don't consider that amenity spaces is
adequate in no stretch of the
imagination the parking bays as we have
already been told by our own policy is
that
on the the way the parking bays are
parallel parking bays they should be six
meters not five point five meters we had
that in our policy and they're not so
they don't comply on the basis that
we've got if we get someone reversing
from their car into those bays the
people who park in front of them or in
parallel to them those people can't move
their car air until the other people
move their car now that's not to say
that they're not going to do it but
we're going to have a lot of shuffling
of cars in their area which is very
small indeed in the in the highway as
there'll be other cars parked there as
well and I fear that this is this is
just a relaxation of air parking which
shouldn't happen at all we have a policy
that parking parking bays should be
adjacent to each other and not in
parallel
other councils don't really like the
parallel parking and we have said we
don't like it the parallel parking and
yet you put it on there I don't see an
area for waste waste bins there's
nothing on there that shows me where the
waste bins are going to be unless you're
gonna put me in the planted area I don't
know but there you are
I wouldn't like to see waste bins in the
parking area in the planting area in any
case there's so many this and getting on
to what has already been said is that
does this council really acknowledge the
residents there are in this rail eat in
and we are supposed to be keeping their
interest at heart a point out our sister
Stanley I was supposed to be judge it
cancer Stanley plays we're supposed to
be judging this application it's just a
a reference to it that green space is
absolutely vital to this community
absolutely vital and
this is not I think that this is not the
right way to go about it
obviously that where the red line is I
daresay there may be a face all the way
around this property I don't see an
entrance to it there is no entrance if
you're going to put the red line all the
way round and there is a I don't see the
entrance how do you get into the
property where do you how do you get you
get improved in cars where the visit to
car park is or the parking spaces where
do you get in because as has already
been noted that there are pathways to
the left and the right of the property
and they're already existing so how do
you get into the property I don't know I
just can't see that I think that really
we should we should look at this again
and again if it is a viable thing that
we are doing Thank You Jeremy thank you
can I just ask for your comment on the
drawing issue means to patients parking
space please if this helps the amenity
space to the ground floor flat is this
area this sort of l-shaped area here and
the terrace to the front so in total the
ground floor flat would have 50 square
meters and then the first floor flat is
provided with a balcony that is nine
square meters which is greater than the
minimum five square meters that
supplementary planning document to
advisors should be provided to flats so
that that relates to the amenity space
that's provided in respect of the
parking
don't go back to the layout Katie so all
of the spaces are going to meet the
preferred base size I take councilor
hallways comment in relation to the
parking standard which states that where
its adjacent to a fence you know in
terms of providing increased
maneuverability about that space it does
say that an additional meet will be
provided but 2.9 meters as a width to
the preferred base size is quite it's
quite wide and would we say in this
sense still be a usable space
there's no disabled Bay provided the
requirement in the parking standard is
that would specifically relate to a
visitor space on the site not in
relation to the the space is
specifically allocated for the flats oh
the bins sorry if we take you back to
the elevation plan
okay yeah so there is sort of part there
sort of inset into the part of the
ground floor of the building so it's
this area here that would be provide the
bin store to the site that's the Wilson
just to really amplify counter the highs
point about I'm a bit uneasy that we've
got a configuration management issue
here that the report doesn't appear to
reference the same drawings and my
concern is that we give approval for
something that doesn't match up so that
that's just an observation and right so
we just yeah
shall I just hopefully provide a bit of
clarity so on the report hmm page nine
point one so the first page of the
report at condition two it sets out the
hreflang numbers which are correct so
they're the correct planned numbers at
not page nine point nine where it
specifically relates to the amenity
space five paragraph five point three
seven that plan reference is just is it
is a typo it should read 201 p4 that is
one of the plans referred to in the
condition
okay the crook said the correct plans
are referencing the report but it should
additionally say 201 P 4 in paragraph
five point three seven that's the layout
plan that shows the wider amenities base
of the site and this other plan shows
the amenity space to the first floor
flat yeah the next one is a question
really the application oh three zero one
one one seven stroke ful that was that's
referenced in the report and that was
where the planning application was
turned down because it was effectively
taken away a piece of open space and
notwithstanding that it that wasn't the
reason for refusal at the last meeting
does this the previous meeting doesn't
supersede the reason where it was turned
down before am I correct in saying that
well I would say is that members need to
determine this application in relation
to material planning considerations we
are mindful that the previous decision
related solely to parking but policy dm3
and all the bullet points relating to
that including the avoidance of lots of
important open space which is a
community benefit is a material
consideration to this application and
just for clarity the reason why I'm
asking this is what I'm trying to get is
we haven't superseded the the report not
the last report but the report when it
was turned down in 2004 so that that
material consideration still stands is
that correct
sorry hopefully I can be clear but in
the determination of this application
policy dm3 in its entirety is a relevant
consideration and that includes point
six which is a clue which is relating to
the avoidance of the loss of open space
that is a consideration to this
application thank you yeah and it
follows on from counsel Stanley the on
the as you look at the the plan it's
actually probably going to be the
Southwest sorry the southeast side of
the boundary so that's where the car
parking is so if so yeah so if you look
at the bottom-left so I bought some
right what what is going to mark the
boundary between the sites and the
footpath nothing I don't think it's
going to be this so this boundary here
would be entirely open so you might have
a different surface material but this is
a this is and you might you might be
able to get away with a low-level fence
here but then potentially you're
creating the same here which you've got
a fence adjacent to a parking bay but
you know you're accessing these parking
spaces across here so what would
delineate the boundary is a change in
surface material the reason why I ask is
actually for the conflict between
pedestrians on the footpath yeah and
yeah and vehicles coming onto the side
so potentially you could have some sort
of low-level or some sort of boundary
treatments along there what you wouldn't
want it to do is to be such or you might
want to set it back slightly because you
wouldn't want it to impact on pedestrian
visibility displays and the like in this
corner here you could I don't think the
boundary treatment is identified
specifically in the application proposal
so essentially that would usually be
dealt with by condition but certainly
this area here for obvious reasons isn't
you know the only delineation is the
surface material across here you could
have some sort of boundary treatments
along now cancer Stanley again okay so
there are you've educated where they
Essenes are which would mean that they
would have to travel right from the one
end of the plot to the other end of the
plot to get the bends out onto a machine
which
Oh Eric we need to just focus not on the
practicalities are living there or just
I think really that is so it's so far
away you know for people to they've got
walk round to put their rubbish in the
beans to come out real no sense of good
planning there as to where they deposit
because they've got walk all the way ran
to deposit their rubbish unit and I
think that that is really sort of
something well I don't think that's in
the right place however I do feel that
we their policy we should have six
meters sorry no I'm mate that sorry
twelve twelve meters in all four parking
as you very well know you don't park
bumper-to-bumper and I don't think the
5.5 he's he's long enough in our policy
when we do parallel parking they're six
meters each and not five point five and
again extra width when we turn I say
we're mitigating the width I do believe
that our policy has been saying should
be a metre wider on one on that side if
he's going to be on the boundary as
aspect as a face so plot our parking by
one should be made wider for that
particular reason
thank you Jim members I think we've
tested all the arguments there might be
some elements of our current policies
that we like or don't like
but our policies are the policies by
which we must make a judgement you want
to
some new points plays then Thank You
chair I I don't actually think we need
any new points I would actually like to
move that we reject this motion on the
grounds that it violates our planning
policy dm3
six on the grounds in fact that's it on
that background alone and would you like
to just expand on that one a little bit
move on completely conversant with diem
yeah I I think this is still a material
matter and that's been confirmed by
offices this surround the avoiding loss
of land is used by the current community
and whilst the previous application was
rejected on the parking grounds this
application is slightly different it
doesn't only change the layout of the
parking it affects the amenity space and
I don't believe this rejection
supersedes the rejection in 2004 anyway
therefore I move that we reject this on
the grounds that it removes land that is
valuable to the current residence and
violates our policy dm3 six of our core
strategy okay thank you right thank you
for that clarity members does anyone
else wish to speak on the motion for
refusal we have a motion for refusal
which has been appropriately seconded
officers have noted the detail those
members in favor of the refusal please
indicate
those against
that item is refused that brings us to
the end of tonight's meeting thank you
very much
nice white category I'm quite nice